RACHAD ALAO: My name
is Rachad, and I
lead Android's media framework.
Media is an integral
part of our life,
bringing us together,
enabling us to share emotions
through music,
pictures and video.
Today we'll discuss how to
create these experiences
and share them with Android.
First, Glenn and Andy
from the media team
will start with a
little story on how
to build great audio
experiences with Android.
Then Lajos and
Ollie will continue
with great video experiences.
And finally, Eddy
will introduce us
to a very compelling way of
building camera application.
Now, please welcome
Glenn and Andy for audio.
[APPLAUSE]
GLENN KASTEN: Hi, all you
audiophiles, videophiles,
and cameraphiles.
I'm Glenn Kasten
from Android audio,
and my focus is on performance.
So given performance, I
love integers in audio.
Integers are simple,
fast, and reliable.
You just can't go
wrong with integers.
In fact, some of my best
friends are integers.
I'd like you to meet two of my
favorite buddies-- Min and Max.
When it comes to audio,
integers are ideal.
Fixed-point, too.
16-bit PCM is where it's at.
I just wish it didn't clip.
That's why in Android
the entire data pipeline
is almost all 16-bit PCM.
ANDY HUNG: Uh, wait
a minute Glenn.
That's so 1980s!
16-bit PCM was fine
for the days of CDs.
But come on!
It's 2014!
In L Developer Preview
we're introducing
floating-point audio, starting
with the audio track data.
We've already updated
part of the pipeline,
and now are planning
out the rest.
There'll be significant
benefits when
the entire pipeline
is converted.
GLENN KASTEN: But
why floating point?
That's so inefficient!
ANDY HUNG: Floating-point
can be just as fast
as integers on
modern processors--
especially with [? Cindy ?]
and auto-order execution.
Floating-point improves
quality and helps
with the clipping, too.
Check out our I/O Bytes "Will
it Float?" to learn more
GLENN KASTEN: Will it float?
Hmm.
ANDY HUNG: Don't worry.
The audio endpoints
are still integer.
GLENN KASTEN: Oh, whew!
And the endpoints can
have more than 16 bits.
Woo-hoo!
Now, about that resampler box.
Andy, you're not
changing that, I hope.
Don't mess with my linear
interpolator, the fastest
resampler in the West.
ANDY HUNG: Glenn,
that's so old school.
In L Developer
Preview we've worked
to improve our resamplers.
Better quality through
reduced aliasing.
Check out this spectrogram
of a sine sweep.
Before, on the top, shows
the aliasing and harmonics;
and after, on the
bottom, is clear.
We've also improved
at twice the speed.
So we also dynamically
compute our resampling filters
to adjust for your
sampling ratios.
GLENN KASTEN: This clicker.
There we go!
OK.
ANDY HUNG: This is all
built into the framework.
So you can mix, play, and
record at different sample rates
with great quality.
But don't use resamplers
if you don't need to,
because it consumes CPU
and adds to latency.
GLENN KASTEN: Latency?
Did somebody say latency?
That is my favorite topic!
I love latency!
In fact, here comes one
of my favorite developers.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: What do
you mean, you love latency?
GLENN KASTEN: Oh, I mean
I love reducing latency.
Sorry about that.
Anyway, I'd like you to meet
Christian Howes from StarMaker
Interactive.
And I'm just going to
let him tell his story.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: So StarMaker
is a global talent discovery
and enablement network.
We make singing games for your
mobile device and a platform
for you to share your
talent with the world.
Our goal is to make singing
fun again for everyone,
and finding great talent
amongst our user base.
But for me it's also personal.
I'm a percussionist, a
professionally trained
musician, and an educator.
And I want to bring
the on-stage experience
to people who wouldn't
normally have that opportunity.
GLENN KASTEN: When
we first met, you
didn't seem too happy
with Android audio.
What was the problem, Christian?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Well,
part of the experience
of being on stage is to
hear yourself singing,
to be a part of the
music, inside that music.
Anything that takes away from
that just ruins the experience.
And I couldn't get that
feeling on Android.
GLENN KASTEN: Can you
show us what you mean?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: (VOICE
ECHOING) Um, here.
Um, here.
Let me see.
Can hear me now?
Can you hear me now?
GLENN KASTEN: What?
Is that delay from Android?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Yes,
that's exactly what
we're talking about.
It's like singing to yourself
across the Grand Canyon.
Hearing a delay while
you're singing just
takes you out of the experience.
GLENN KASTEN: But
come on, Christian,
I heard a couple of
seconds of latency.
That's ridiculous.
That's crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
If you do a Google
search for Android audio,
this is number five,
I believe-- or four.
There have been some
wild rumors out there.
Yes, the latency has been
high, but not this high.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Yeah.
So folks, that demo was
a bit of an exaggeration,
just for the explanation.
But you get the point.
The latency is annoying.
So I'm going to do a quick demo
of what our app is actually
like right now.
I'm going to shut off my mic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLENN KASTEN: So Christian, cut.
Cut, cut, cut.
Hold on a second.
OK.
The instrumentals were
great, but I'm sorry.
I didn't even hear you at all.
What's up?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Well,
that's the point.
We had to disable the
real time feedback because
of the latency.
Users complained because
our most important feature
is missing from the app.
GLENN KASTEN: Well, it seems
like kind of a nice app.
I mean it's almost fun.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Yeah,
but we're missing
the "you" in the performance.
GLENN KASTEN: I'll say.
So how bad was the round
trip latency-- or rather,
is the round trip latency?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Well,
it's not the 12 seconds
that we saw earlier.
It's not two seconds.
But it is noticeable.
We've measured 200
milliseconds or more.
Enough that we ignored Android
completely until our users
clamored loudly enough.
When we finally
implemented the app,
we had to disable this real time
monitoring of the user vocals.
We've tried to account
for the latency
and still make a good quality
recording for the user
to share, but we still
had trouble with that too.
GLENN KASTEN: Hey, Christian,
we can figure this out.
Show us how it works inside.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: All right.
So our current app is still
using the Java-based solution.
We have two MP3 audio
files-- the instrumental
and the guide vocal tracks.
We decode and mix those files
to play on the headphones.
Then we record the microphone
input of the user singing,
pass it through an
audio processing library
for pitch detection
and pitch correction.
As the user is singing, we
also mix the instrumental track
with the processed
microphone stream
and encode that into an
AAC file for the user
to listen to and
then later share.
What we really want
to do is have this all
happen fast enough that
that processed microphone
input could be mixed in
with the headphones for you
to hear it in real time.
That's also going to improve
our scoring algorithm
and have a more accurate
timing of the pitch data.
GLENN KASTEN: So at
last year's-- I'm sorry,
hold on a second, let
me go back to that.
Oh well.
This clicker is wild.
At last year's I/O, [? Rafe ?]
[? Lavine ?] and I presented
reduced audio output latency.
Did you even try
those techniques?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Well, no.
We never did.
We read the blog post and saw
it probably wasn't ready yet.
The other thing is
last year's talk
was all about output latency,
and what was important
for our app is
the input latency.
We need to get that audio
moving through the pipeline
just so much faster.
GLENN KASTEN: So I
hear you, Christian.
And I hear all of
you developers too.
No, I don't love mic latency.
I've actually been
working on this.
And we're going to share
our results with you today.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Right.
So Glenn has shared
his progress with me,
and I want to show you what
we've been doing with it.
We've tried out the new reduced
latency APIs in the L Developer
Preview.
I'm going to shut off
my lapel mic again,
and this time you'll hear me
actually sing through the app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLENN KASTEN: Hey, Christian!
I can hear you!
[APPLAUSE]
Sounds great.
And how's the latency?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: It's
dramatically improved.
It's finally good enough
that, with the changes
we've done together, I can
turn on that real time audio
monitoring.
GLENN KASTEN: And did you
have to change anything
in your app to do this?
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Well,
it's never that simple.
Of course, we had to
make a few changes.
We followed last
year's recommendations,
and re-implemented
our entire pipeline
in the open SL ES APIs.
So a full C re-implementation.
But it actually simplified our
audio pipeline significantly.
There's fewer steps
now, and less places
for the synchronization
to get off,
so our recording's
going to be better,
and you're going to hear
the voice in real time.
GLENN KASTEN: And did
you run into any problems
when you re-implemented?
CHRISTIAN HOWES:
Well, there were
a few challenges along the way.
I'm going to tell you
about a couple of them.
We do a significant amount
of digital signal processing
with our pitch detection
and pitch correction.
The CPU load of this
can be kind of bursty,
which is really awkward with
the smaller buffer sizes.
Also we had to
implement a resampler,
because the different
hardware devices expect
different things.
I really wish we
had that resampler
that Andy was just
talking about.
And we don't actually yet
have this new pipeline
in our app proper.
GLENN KASTEN: Wow.
Those are pretty hard problems.
CHRISTIAN HOWES: Yes, but
they were all solvable.
And you know what?
The user doesn't really care.
Everything that
we're trying to do
is get the user inside
the performance.
Our users just want to
connect with the artists
and to be a part of the song.
GLENN KASTEN: Thanks, Christian.
Professional musicians
and recording engineers
expect latency less
than 10 milliseconds.
We're not there yet.
But we have made
progress in the platform,
and it will enable
new applications
that are currently not possible.
There are a lot of difficult
hardware and system integration
issues that we need
to work through
so that we can scale this
up to the entire ecosystem.
I want to thank
all of our partners
who have contributed-- in
particular, Christian Howes
from StarMaker Interactive.
CHRISTIAN HOWES:
Thank you, Glenn
[APPLAUSE]
GLENN KASTEN: And I'm hoping
she's in the audience.
Amanda [? Chowdhury ?]
from Smule
has also given us very
valuable feedback.
[APPLAUSE]
So we've just seen several
improvements in Android audio.
A higher quality
floating-point pipeline,
new resamplers, and my favorite,
reduced round trip latency.
So the big question is,
what do we do with all this?
We've seen one example of what
we can do in terms of singing.
I personally am really
excited about real time voice
processing, including
ordinary speech processing.
And another pet favorite of
mine is augmented reality.
But the big question is,
what do you want, Andy?
ANDY HUNG: I'm into
audio signal processing,
and I really want the
improved audio quality.
GLENN KASTEN: And
how about all of you?
What do you want to do?
So thank you all for coming.
We're going to be available
after this session for Q&A--
Christian, myself, and Andy--
to talk about any questions
you have about Android audio,
and particularly the problem
areas that came up
during Christian's demo.
Please check out
the links above,
and be sure to watch
our I/O Bytes videos.
ANDY HUNG: And now we hand off
to Lajos from Android video.
GLENN KASTEN: Thank you.
LAJOS MOLNAR: All right.
All right.
So let's talk about video.
First, I want you to
ponder this question.
If a picture is worth a thousand
words, what is a video worth?
Hopefully, more than a thousand.
Maybe 24,000 a second.
So why is video so hot?
Perhaps this clip for
our Nexus 5 campaign
can shed light to that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So video is hot, because
it's the next best
thing to being in the moment, to
being with the people that you
love, and to satisfy
our desire to see.
People have been hungry for
rich, multi-sensory, multimedia
experiences from the beginning.
They want to capture
and share memories.
They want to create, and
they want to communicate.
In fact, video has been
around for nearly 140 years.
A Huffington Post
editorial actually
asked a very similar question
about the birth of video,
and concluded that in today's
world of social media,
video may be worth
more than ever before.
And Android is
positioned perfectly
to take advantage of that.
Android has both high-
and low-level interfaces
that enable you to create
great multimedia experiences.
The high-level interfaces like
MediaPlayer, MediaRecorder
work by themselves.
And the lower-level ones,
MediaCodec and his friends,
they work as a team.
For some applications, the
higher level interfaces
are enough.
Plus, they are supporting
the widest range of devices.
For others,
applications that want
to have the best
multimedia experience,
they use both interfaces.
They take advantage
of the low-level APIs
on newer devices to provide a
polished, fine-tuned behavior.
And they provide
fallback behavior
on older devices using
the high-level interfaces.
And then there are
apps that require
the low-level interfaces
for their operations,
such as media editing, or some
kind of creative applications.
And these are not enabled
by the high-level API.
So there are really no wrong
answers of which APIs to use.
Today, video is everywhere.
In the developed
world, basically you
can take video for granted.
What increases is
the quality bar.
So I want you to see how-- we're
going to go through a few use
cases to see how Android
can help you aim higher.
So one of my
favorite pastimes is
watching movies-- and
probably for many others.
Video playback has been a
standard feature of Android
since the beginning, and we
continue to make improvements.
Bandwidth remains a constant
battle on mobile devices.
So with the L
Developer Preview we
are supporting the best
codecs, such as VP9 and HEVC.
And these give you
higher resolutions
for the same bandwidth.
In order to take advantage
of the available bandwidth,
KitKat introduced support
for adaptive playback,
where you can seamlessly
change the video resolution
during playback.
And in the L
Developer Preview, we
have dramatically
improved the scheduling
of video playback, which results
in less jitters, smoother pans,
and less interference
from system events.
So here's Ollie to tell you
about YouTube and Play Movies,
and how they are taking
advantage of the media APIs.
OLIVER WOODMAN: Hello.
So my name's Oliver Woodman.
I work on the Play Movies and
YouTube application teams.
And I'm specifically
focused on video playback.
So it can be a bit of
a challenge on Android.
So I want to just tell you
a little bit about how we're
using these APIs internally at
Google in our own applications,
and about some of the results
that we're able to achieve.
So when we talk about
high-level and low-level APIs,
as Lajos mentioned, when we're
talking about high-level APIs,
for video playback we're really
interested in MediaPlayer.
So it's kind of self-contained.
It does everything for you.
And both Play Movies and
YouTube use MediaPlayer
on devices that don't have
the newer, low-level APIs.
So we effectively just
have a kind of thin shim
which wraps MediaPlayer,
and effectively MediaPlayer
does everything for us.
But on newer devices, we
have these low-level APIs.
So we're really interested
in MediaExtractor,
which does networking
and buffering and sample
extraction of media.
MediaCodec, which will take
these samples and decode them.
AudioTrack, which will play
decoded audio out of speakers.
And then MediaDrm
as well, which will
handle encrypted playbacks.
So while these
APIs are available,
we've actually decided to
take a different approach.
And we've developed an
application-level media player
called ExoPlayer, which is
predominantly written in Java
and calls through to
these low-level APIs.
So we pull up the player logic,
and actually for Play Movies
and for YouTube we
actually also pull up
the networking, buffering,
and extraction components
and re-implement them on
that application layer.
So there are a number of
reasons why this is a good idea,
and you should think
about doing this, too.
Firstly, it just gives
you a lot more control.
So previously, all this logic
which is part of the framework
is now part of your app.
You can easily update it.
You can easily customize it
to suit your exact use case.
And you can use the
implement features
that MediaPlayer
just doesn't support.
And the main thing
that we've done
in terms of
implementing features
is we've added support for
Play Movies and YouTube
to play DASH streams, which is
a type of adaptive streaming
technology.
So it's similar to other
similar streaming technologies.
It's nothing particularly new.
It allows you to encode
your video streams
in multiple resolutions
and bit rates.
And then, during playback,
you can adapt the quality
that you're
delivering to the user
by requesting small chunks
from different streams
and, depending on the
network conditions,
you can then vary the
quality that you're actually
requesting in order to give the
best resolution without giving
the user rebuffers.
So in terms of why you
should want to do this,
we've been doing this on
newer devices for a while
now in Play Movies,
and we've been
seeing some pretty good results.
So here are a few.
So compared with the old way of
doing things using MediaPlayer,
we find that with
ExoPlayer DASH playbacks,
we can shave 65% off
start-up latency--
so the initial buffering
spinner before the video
starts playing.
We're able to reduce
rebuffering rate significantly.
So this is the number of
playbacks-- so the fraction
of playbacks that the user will
see a rebuffer interrupting
their playback at some point.
We have reduced that by 40%.
And we've done all this while
simultaneously giving the user
higher quality content.
So the video resolution
in terms of height
is improved by about
11% on average.
So these are really
great results.
We're really happy
about what we're doing
and how we're improving
the experience.
And we really think that
people should investigate
this kind of approach
as well themselves.
But ExoPlayer, our
application-level media player,
it took some time to build.
It's about 16,000 lines of code.
And the code is
relatively complex.
So delivering-- building on
top of these low-level APIs
can be a bit of a challenge
just by their nature.
And for that reason we're
giving you ExoPlayer.
We're open-sourcing it.
It's on GitHub already.
Go and check it out.
And this is pretty much
the exact same core player
technology that we're using
in our Play Movies and YouTube
applications.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you!
So it supports DASH,
although we're still
working on widening the range
of manifests that we support.
But pretty much
everything is there,
and we're continuing to work
on improving coverage there.
It also supports
SmoothStreaming,
which is a similar
adaptive technology.
And we've deliberately
designed it to be extensible.
Obviously, you can just take
the source code and change it.
But equally, we've made
it easy to inject things
into the library,
so you can do things
like inject your own custom
network stack if you want to,
inject a persistent cache.
And really it's just a much more
powerful model for development.
So that's what we've been doing
in YouTube and Play Movies.
Before I finish,
I just want to say
that we learned quite a lot
from developing this new media
player ourselves, and we've been
feeding what we've learned back
into making our low-level
APIs in the Android framework
itself even better
than they are already.
So this started with Kitkat.
We realized it was
quite hard to achieve
very accurate audio-video sync.
You could get pretty close, but
there was some unknown latency
in the audio track, though
there was no way to query.
So we fixed that back in KitKat.
We added a new getTimestamp API
that lets you figure this out.
And for the devices running
older versions of the Android
operating system, ExoPlayer
also has a workaround
which fixes the
audio-video sync problem.
There was also-- it's
just another niggle,
but it's pretty annoying
if you're a developer.
AudioTrack's write methods
required you to give it
a byte array, but
actually, when you
decode audio using
a MediaCodec API,
you actually get a byte buffer.
So you had to do
this pointless copy
just to get data from
one place to another.
Now L Developer
Preview fixes that.
We've added a write method
that takes a byte buffer.
And whilst we were
at it, we also
added a non-blocking
variant in order
to do non-blocking writes.
And finally, but probably
most importantly,
is the problem of
smooth video playback.
So until now, you've
had to time your calls
to MediacCodec release
output buffer yourself.
And you have to evenly space
these so that the actual frames
are dispatched in
an even manner.
And if you're running the
old VM for Android-- so
Dalvik-- this could be a problem
if your garbage collector came
and paused your thread
at the exact time
you were supposed to
release the frame.
You could get pretty good.
You had to be pretty
careful about not
generating too much garbage.
If you went to our
tech talk earlier,
you will know that
things are much better,
and have largely made
this issue go away.
We've actually
gone a bit further,
and we've added a
new method which
allows you to release
a frame ahead of time
specifying a time, a short
period in the future,
where you would actually like
that frame to hit the screen.
And we've seen that this
really helps improve
the smoothness of video
playback by letting the really
low-level parts of Android
time the frame release,
and we've been investing
some effort there in order
to make sure it does a
really good job of that.
So with that, I'd
like to hand back
to Lajos, who's
going to tell you
some more experiences,
building experiences,
on the Android APIs.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LAJOS MOLNAR: All right.
Thanks, Ollie.
So let's look at
another example.
We saw how Android can help
you accomplish the real time
demands of video playback.
But Android's
low-level media APIs
are also perfect for
media processing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So that was Auto Awesome
Movie from Google+,
and it is a great example of
how to use the lower level media
APIs to create content.
You can use these interfaces
as building blocks.
And they beautifully integrate
with GL textures and shaders.
For example, you can output
decoded video onto a texture--
even multiple videos.
And then you can blend them
together using a GL shader.
And then you can
capture the video
from the resulting
texture and encode it.
So that's video editing.
Or you can apply filters through
the audio or video buffers
to extract the
information from them.
For example you can use a GLES
shader to detect scene changes
or changes in color balance.
So then, the question
is, what can you
do with these low
level building blocks?
So I assert that it
really depends on you.
What can you do?
So consider all the connectivity
and additional sensors
that are on a mobile
device, and there's
something amazing
waiting to be created.
So let's look at
another example that
uses video, the camera, and
connectivity to help you
connect to the people you love,
even when they are far away.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
WOMAN (ON VIDEO):
It's a chance that he
has to interact
with his children,
because he misses out
on so many memories.
He's making a memory by
telling these stories,
and interacting with them.
That's just phenomenal.
You can't even begin to imagine.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LAJOS MOLNAR: So
that was Hangout,
which also uses the
low-level media APIs
to do real time communication.
So let's start from a
basic camera preview.
I mean you can capture
the surface-- the camera
preview buffers, and
apply a GL shader-- maybe
add a little hat.
And then compress it.
You can also compress
a different stream
from the same source.
Maybe a different hat, or maybe
a lower resolution content
for lower bandwidth.
Then you send the packets
across the network.
And then, on the
receiver's side,
you use the adaptive playback
features to seamlessly switch
between the different streams.
So this is basically the
basic operation of Hangouts.
So we are adding a couple
of new features that
will be fully exposed
in the next release,
such as dynamic encoded bitrate
control and temporal layering.
In temporal layering, the
individual video frames
are divided into layers.
So the idea is
that you should be
able to decode all
the frames in a layer
without any frames
in a higher layer.
So this allows more radical
bitrate control, because you
can discard-- not
even transmit--
whole sets of buffers.
For example, when
you use three layers,
Layer 0 contains
every fourth frame.
So it's at a quarter frame rate.
Layer 1 also contains
every fourth frame.
But together with Layer 0,
now the video is half rate.
And then Layer 2 contains
the remaining frames.
But here, notice that
each frame is droppable.
So another thing that people
like to do is share stuff.
So if you're an Android mobile
user with this tiny screen,
and then you come across a
large, beautiful display,
you would want to
take advantage of it.
Wouldn't you?
So Android, by default,
mirrors your activity
onto external displays.
And that works fine.
But why not enhance
your application
by providing a differentiated
specific content
on the second screen?
You can use MediaRouter
and DisplayManager
to detect the
additional display,
and then you create a
presentation to actually show
the specific content on it.
So there are two sample
apps in the Android
and the Android SDK
that demonstrate
to you how to do this.
Additionally, you can take
advantage of nearby Google Cast
devices, such as Chromecast or
an Android TV device and fling
content onto them.
So this, you use a
Google Cast SDK for that,
and it's supported for all
Android 2.3 or later devices.
Or, after KitKat MR1, you
can also present or mirror
onto these devices.
And now, the icing on the cake.
We have not forgotten about
you, native developers,
if you're in the room.
So the low-level media APIs
are now available in the NDK.
And thes APIs mimic
the Java ones.
[APPLAUSE]
And you can use them on
32-bit or 64-bit binaries.
And hopefully, you visited
the NDK booth already.
But if not, check it out.
There's still some specific
content going on there.
So I want you to think about
how you can take advantage
of these Android
media building blocks,
and where with
media or video add
to the delight of your users.
And what is unique about
the [INAUDIBLE] experience
that you could take
advantage of to create
that extra magic for
your application?
For more in-depth coverage
of our media APIs,
or of ExoPlayer, check
out our I/O Bytes.
Maybe you already
have seen them.
And check out ExoPlayer source.
Now, Eddy will tell
you about what's
new in the camera framework.
EDDY TALVALA: Thanks, Lajos.
So I'm Eddy Talvala.
I'm the Tech Lead for
Android's Camera framework.
And I'm here on
behalf of my team
to talk about what we've been
doing for the last few years
in Android Camera.
Cameras are great.
You can use them to do
all sorts of things.
You can use them to
record your memories.
You can use them to share
experiences you've had.
You can use them to
document the world.
And if you're actually
good at photography,
which I'd like to be one day,
you can actually create art.
Like this.
And the mobile devices
have been getting
better and better every year
in terms of their cameras.
The hardware is getting better.
They're getting faster.
And really I think
mobile devices
can become better cameras
than anything else
out there, because they have so
much more than just the camera.
They have a lot of
additional sensors.
They have a whole lot
of computing power,
both the CPU and the GPU.
They're connected
to the network,
so they can connect
to the world and know
about the context of where you
are, what you've been doing,
and connect to additional
resources from the cloud.
But right now, if you want to
build an advanced camera API,
it turns out the current
camera APIs on Android
really are holding us back.
Advanced camera applications
want more control
of capture, more control
of post-processing,
and they want to do
everything really fast.
And right now the
Android camera API
has limited capture controls.
It's very hard-wired
operating mode.
You're either taking
a picture or recording
a video-- you can't do both.
Very minimal feedback
on what's actually
going on in the
whole camera system.
And they are either very
slow at high resolution
or, if you want to go fast,
you're limited to video rates.
And they're completely
unsynchronized.
So it's pretty much a
point and shoot camera.
If you could just press
the buttons by software,
is what the API is.
So what I'm going
to talk about today
is our new camera API,
which we built totally
from the ground up to address
these challenging new camera
applications.
It has a pipeline
model and operates--
allows you to get full
manual control of capture
and post-processing.
The pipeline model is
fully synchronized,
and you get feedback for
every capture you take.
And the data coming out of this
you can have multiple image
streams coming out at full
resolution, full frame rate.
And it's all synchronized.
So with the old API, if you want
a full resolution 8 megapixel
picture from your
Nexus 5, this is
what you get-- one
to three frames
per second at 8 megapixels.
With the exact same hardware
on the L Developer Preview
in our new API, you can do this.
30 frames per second, 8
megapixels, uncompressed YUV.
[APPLAUSE]
Or even this.
Again, 30 frames per second,
variable exposure time,
full resolution.
So what are we
doing differently?
What are we doing
to enable this?
Because you know, it turns out
that if you went back in time,
the Galaxy Nexus could
actually, at the low levels,
capture 30 frames a
second at 5 megapixels--
its maximum resolution.
But this wasn't
available in the API.
So how come?
So this is a very rough
diagram of a real camera.
There is a sensor.
There is an image processor.
And both of them
have multiple stages
that the image goes through.
And of course, each
of these stages
has some settings, like the
exposure time, or the gamma
curve, or whatever.
So I've marked the
settings for each stage
here with a little yellow S.
When you're streaming
data through for video
or for high resolution--
high rate of capture-- each
of these pipelines is busy
processing a different image.
So here you can see
image number one
has finished processing, has
been sent the application,
has gotten all the
yellow settings applied.
So with the old API, if you
now change the parameters using
the set parameters call,
you do a global change.
All the parameters change at
once to the red parameters.
And then, if you look at what
happens to the images flowing
through the pipeline,
some of them
have already been processed
through the yellow stages,
and now they'll get
red settings instead.
So if you look at the output,
the settings are inconsistent.
Your first image is
all yellow settings.
The last image is all red.
But everything in
between is inconsistent.
You don't actually know if you
have the exposure you wanted,
or the gamma curve you wanted.
You have some mix.
And of course, since every
Android device potentially
has a different set
of pipeline stages,
you really have no
idea how long it'll
take for any given
setting to propagate.
So if you want to do
something really fast,
you want to take
a burst of images,
it's very difficult to do,
because you don't really
know when it will happen
and when you'll be done.
So you could just slow down.
And this is what
usually happens when
you take high-resolution
pictures.
So you just send one
image through at a time.
So, settings are
consistent, but you're now
going 1/6 the speed as before.
So this isn't very suitable for
advanced applications as well.
So instead, what we do now is
that we look at the problem
differently.
Each of the images that
go through the system
have the settings
attached to them.
So the settings flow through
the pipeline with the images
instead of being
these global things.
So instead of having a black
box that sends you data,
you send in requests
for images, and they
get filled along as they
flow through the pipeline.
So here I have some yellow,
blue, and red settings.
And as they flow
through the system
the settings go along
with image buffers,
and everything is consistent
at consistent settings
and high frame rate.
And there aren't any modes here.
The system is simply a
streaming flowing API.
You provide a
request and now it's
common data that's
synchronized to what you want.
So let's take a quick look at
the building blocks of the API
that implements this
pipeline architecture.
To start off with, you
just get a camera manager
from the getSystemService call.
The camera manager lets you
enumerate camera devices.
Query their characteristics,
like which way
they're pointing.
And then you can open them.
So I get the information
first, and then you
decide it's the camera you want.
You open it.
The camera device lets you
do two important things.
First, it lets you create an
individual capture session.
You take a set of
outputs that you
want to target for
this session and use
it to create a CaptureSession.
And the outputs are
the Android surfaces.
And then you can
create Capture Request.
Each Capture Request again
defines all the settings
for a single image that's going
to come out of the system.
And then you start sending
them to the session.
Session captures the
image asynchronously,
and when it's done it
sends you back the metadata
about the result.
So the characteristics
include things
like the available manual
exposure times, the resolutions
and formats supported
by this device,
possible available
autofocus modes,
and the general capability
flags of this device.
The requests are all of the
settings for a single capture.
Here we're asking for
one millisecond exposure
time, color correction
gains for post processing,
and a continuous autofocus mode.
And the request also
include which of the targets
you configured for this
session you actually
want to use for this request.
So, for example, if you
configure the session
with a preview output and a
high resolution shaping output,
you might want some
of your requests
to test target preview
for a steady viewfinder,
and some of them that
are user-triggered
provide the shaping data.
So any subset of the
configure services
can be used in each request.
And then, on the output,
you get the result.
It contains time
stamps, the state
of devices like the flash--
here the flash is fired.
The autofocus is
successfully locked
and it says there's a face
in this particular image.
And you know that it was
exactly capture request-- which
capture request that
you sent in that
was captured that
has these statistics.
So you can correlate
this to image data
and analyze it and know
exactly what you got.
So putting this
all together, you
start out with a set of
outputs you care about.
Here, some examples
are SurfaceView,
RenderScript allocation,
an ImageReader for a JPEG,
a MediaCodec for video
encoding, or SurfaceTexture
to send to open GL.
You get the surfaces from them.
You create a capture session.
And creating the session also
defines your maximum frame
rate.
It looks at the surfaces
you've provided.
It looks at the
resolutions you want.
And the maximum resolution
defines how fast
you can actually run the system.
On the Nexus 5 we can run at
30 frames per second for 8
megapixel maximum output,
but this may vary per device.
And then, once you've
configured a session,
you start creating capture
requests and sending them.
So everything is asynchronous.
The requests go
into a queue, get
processed by the
hardware in the pipeline.
As the requests are
processed, filled buffers
are sent to your outputs
with time stamps,
and then results with time
stamps are sent to the queue
once the captures are complete.
And this is the entire
flow of the API.
There aren't any other modes.
There's no video mode.
There's no still-capture mode.
You simply decide what
requests you want.
You send them in at
the rate you want,
and they come out
when they're done.
At high rates, of course,
so you can have as many
of them in the
queue as you'd like.
So I already talked about
the different outputs.
Different destinations.
You can get output in
uncompressed YUV, compressed
JPEG, or RAW_SENSOR data.
And there's a whole
lot of controls,
and I'm not going to
talk about all of them.
You control a bunch
of manual controls,
and there's still
a bunch of controls
for the automatic side--
exposure, autofocus,
and auto white balance.
We have a large number of camera
characteristics fields to read.
All the settings, possible
ranges from manual control.
A lot of information
about the sensor color
spaces for raw
sensor processing,
and the information
about the hardware,
the lensing capabilities.
And on the result side,
we have information
about the state of all
the automatic algorithms
if you're running them, and
the state of the hardware--
like if the flash
fired and so on.
We also provide some statistics
like the neutral color point
of the image, whether
there are faces,
and what the lens shading
compensation map is.
And we'll have a number
of Android DevBytes videos
about this.
The first one should
be going up soon.
I'm getting the
very basics going.
One important note
that for the L Preview,
this only works on the Nexus 5.
The Nexus 7 or the Emulator
Images don't run the new API.
If you try, it will crash
in some horrible way.
So that's a very brief
tour of what the API is.
The question is, what can
you actually do with it?
So our first serious
shipping application is HDR+
on the Nexus 5.
It's the Nexus 5's high dynamic
range and low-light mode.
It was shipped using a
pre-release version of our API
in Android KitKat.
So here's a sample image.
A very hard problem.
This is a dimly
lit party, and this
is a picture of a Nexus 5
standard picture capture
cropped a bit.
So it's very dark.
So the denoising algorithms
had to do a lot of work,
and the picture, as a result,
is very blurry and still kind of
splotchy.
So let's try HDR+.
HDR+ in 0.9 seconds captures
115 megabytes of data,
analyzes the scene, and
produces an output result
that's on the right.
As you can see, it's a lot
sharper, it's a lot less noisy,
and the dynamic range
is actually improved.
You can see the television
in the background.
If I zoom up close
to the eye here,
you can see on the left that
there's barely any detail
in the regular capture, where
there's quite a bit of detail
in the HDR+ and you can see
the improved dynamic range.
So this has been shipping.
This uses the advanced
capabilities of the API
for manual capture
in high-rate bursts.
Another possibility you
could do with the API
is taking a stack of images
with a bunch of different depths
very quickly.
So here we take--
move the Nexus 5 lens
from far to near focus
in about 0.8 seconds
capturing a set of 8
megapixel images, as we go.
You can now take
this burst of images
and analyze it
for, perhaps, make
an image that's in
focus everywhere,
or create some
sort of depth map.
There's a number
of applications.
We're also enabling support
for Adobe DNG raw formats
in the Android frameworks.
So we will provide unsupported
devices, including the Nexus 5.
They will provide
raw sensor data
that can either be
analyzed by the app,
or saved into a DNG
file that can then
be opened in professional
post-processing applications
like Lightroom, Aperture.
Or you can even upload
to Google Photos,
and they'll actually
happily process your DNGs.
And finally, I'm going
to try a demo application
of another interesting
application.
Let's see if this works.
Let's see this work-- camera.
All right.
So Rachad is going
to be a model, here.
Stand right about there.
So.
All right.
So as you can see here,
this is a regular viewfinder
on the Nexus 5.
You can see Rachad just
fine, but the audience
is a little dark.
So we have-- I said we have
manual exposure control.
So let's see if
we can do better.
Let's switch to manual exposure.
And the default exposure's
a little bright on Rachad
and still too dark
on the audience.
And to make this thing a
little more interesting,
this is not actually
just manual exposure.
This is actually a
split-screen manual exposure.
So I'm going to brighten
up the audience a bit.
And we get some really
bad glare from the lights
there, unfortunately.
But you can see
that on the right
I can see Rachad just fine.
On the left, I can
see the audience.
And if I pan over the
audience, it's black.
And if I pan the other way,
Rachad is a little overexposed.
So now I can see
both sides, but I'd
like to see it at the
same time, of course.
So let's use RenderScript.
And we have a direct
efficient copy
in our data processing
path into RenderScript.
And blend this into a single
high-dynamic range viewfinder.
So now you can see both Rachad
on the right and the audience
on the left, and the viewfinder
is still rather smooth.
Actually could be
a little smoother.
Notice that on the right,
I'm getting feedback
about the exposure time.
And the exposure
time had actually
gotten long enough
that we were starting
to drop the frame rate.
So let me drop it back
it down to demonstrate
that this is actually
quite smooth.
And you can compare
regular viewfinder.
Rachad is still dark, the
audience is completely gone.
Split screen, and then the blend
where you can see everything.
And this all runs at
30 frames per second.
And if you want to know what the
secret is-- how do we actually
do a split screen-- we don't
actually have a fancy sensor.
We're actually just alternating
exposures every other frame
in a continuous burst.
So the sensor's not--
every other frame is long,
every other frame is
short, and we simply
blend the last
images we get out.
So this is the kind
of thing you can
do when you're not limited
to modes like burst.
The API has one
mode of operation.
And it can do bursts, it
can do streaming bursts,
it can do single images.
Whatever you want.
All right.
Thank you, Rachad.
[APPLAUSE]
So in summary, we made a
new Camera API for Android.
We think it's pretty awesome.
We really hope to get a lot of
feedback during the L Preview
to help us guide
what to do next,
and to get feedback on
bugs, because there's still
some rough edges we know about.
So please take it for
a spin on the Nexus 5.
Let us know what you think.
And I'd like to get actually
Rachad back to wrap up.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHAD ALAO: Hello.
Thank you very much.
I hope you enjoyed the session.
We'll all be available
in the corner.
If you have
additional questions,
we'll be happy to answer them.
Thank you!